Speaker 1: Let's see if we can continue.
I guess the audio issue really didn't
seem to be on my end, which is good news,
generally speaking, but sometimes it still
upsets people. Let's go to Sabrina. Sabrina,
you're on the air. So can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 5: I don't really have a question, I was
just reflecting on this whole Rittenhouse trial,
and yeah, I feel where you're coming from, I feel
like he's a huge victim of the whole gun culture,
wrong parenting and God knows what else. I just
really feel for him because he is still a minor.
Speaker 1: Well, he isn't anymore,
but he was at the time of the incident.
Speaker 5: Yeah, but I just wish we were
doing more as a country to sort of address
and address the sort of psychological impact
this has on our children. You know, Kyle was
only 17 at the time, and I know what happened
was tragic, but it's really just heartbreaking
to see to see him with his life and to see
the aftermath of this trial or whatever,
Speaker 1: whatever the verdict is. Well,
you know, his life may not be wasted.
I mean, he may be found not guilty
and then get speaking gigs and become sort of
like a hero of some kind. I actually it remains
to be seen what the trajectory is. He'll have
killed people. He can't undo that. But you know,
I. Let's wait. Is it raining where you are?
Speaker 5: No, it's not. I have a background
fan noise, so it's probably that.
Speaker 1: Oh, I see. Okay. All right. Very good,
Sabrina. Thank you. I appreciate the call.
We're going to watch the verdict very closely.
All right, there is Sabrina. I appreciate
everybody who called in, that's going to do
it for calls today, but I do hope to take
calls again sooner than you might imagine.